All right. Welcome to the DDPS
seminar everyone people we
introduce our invited speaker,
let's go over some rules and
logistics, the same rules and
logistics I have been. I've been
I have been saying for every
DDPS him now, okay, first of
all, please mute yourself during
the talk. But if you have
questions, you can unmute and
ask questions, or huge chat room
to pose your question so that we
can address them in q&a session.
Second, today's DDK seminar is
open to external audiences.
Therefore, no classified
discussion is allowed. And
finally, the talk today will be
recorded and uploaded in our
YouTube channel. That's about
it. Now let me briefly introduce
our speaker today. It is an
honor. It's a great honor to
host Dr. Derek James if he is a
professor of computer science at
Stanford University and a member
of Stanford's Center for
Computer Research in Music and
Acoustics, and the Institute for
computational and mathematical
engineering ICME. He has been a
consulting Senior Research
Scientist at Nvidia research
since 2022. He holds three
degrees in applied mathematics
including a PhD in 2001 from the
University of British Columbia.
In 2002. He joined the School of
Computer Science at Carnegie
Mellon University as an
assistant professor, and later
became an associate professor of
the computer science at Cornell
University. His research
interests include computer
graphics, computer sound,
physically based modeling and
animation and reduced older
physics models. Doug is a
recipient of the National
Science Foundation Career Award
and a fellow of both the Alfred
Sloan Foundation and Guggenheim
Foundation, who received the
ACM, circa 2021 Computer
Graphics Achievement Awards in
2012 Technical Achievement Award
from the Academy of Motion
Picture Arts and Sciences for
the wavelet opulence and the
2013 Carter Yanagi emerging
leadership prize from the
Carnegie Mellon University and
Tokyo University of Technology.
He was the technical paper
Program Chair of ACM shugar
2015, and a consulting Senior
Research Scientist at Pixar
Animation Studios from 2015 to
2020. All right, today, Doug
will talk about recent progress
in reduced order modeling for
computer graphics and sound. I'm
sure he's going to give a vague
talk and no doubt about it. So
please be prepared. Now let me
ask a question to dog just to
make this stays somewhat
informal. Is it okay to ask some
question doc,
yeah, please by all means, you
ask questions. And at any point
I'm gonna I'm going to go
through a lot of material and
think of the talk is kind of an
advertisement for for the
material like the find the
details in the paper. I just
don't have time to go through
everything. But uh, but by all
means, if you have questions,
just you know, shoot,
this is fine. Okay, the first
question is even before you keep
up okay, he you know, I see that
you are passionate not only the
computational science computer
computer science, but also the
music and if you can share a
your favorite music piece with
us. Wow.
Yes, I mean, I love I guess I
love all the things related to
sight and such touch and sound
and how that relates to math and
physics and, and sort of always
been one thing together. You
know, I don't know. How about
punk Gilbert's curse of Castle
dragon. Put that on if you want
to get your energy levels up,
you know that will that will get
you going in the morning.
Kick. I don't know that music,
but I will definitely try. Yeah,
amazing guitarist.
Thank you is yours. Okay, great.
So thanks for coming to the
talk, everybody. So I I've
always been excited, you know,
for the last 20 years about
reduced order modeling about how
to make things fast by doing
things in low dimensions,
speeding up dynamics of
deformable models, allowing that
to be used to do faster GPU
rendering of the models the
motion and and being able to use
rigid store representations for
faster collision processing,
contact processing, supporting
haptic feedback at kilohertz
rates and even sound without
having to deform everything. So,
you know, restore models just as
love them. Some things you have
to, you know, you need full
dimensions to do if you want a
lot of details and or things
that you haven't seen before,
don't know what the basis is.
And, and so that kind of leads
to the first part of the talk.
And the second part is going to
be about about fluids, and the
sounds that water makes, and how
to compute those using reduced
order models. So let me see how
to do this. Okay, so. So, I
guess I want to start by
thanking, you know, my PhD
students. So this is worked by
two amazing PhD students. The
first one is Eris. Eris has done
a lot of incredible work on
simulating the form of models.
And that's related to the
progressive physics or
progressive methods that she
developed. That's the first part
of the talk. The second part is
by Congress. And Congress has
been working on doing fast
simulation of fluid sounds, and
also GPU acoustics and things
like that, to basically make the
simulation of everything we can
visually animate, also have
sound in a practical way. So
this, like, the future is
include sound that's a first
class, physical primitive. Okay,
so to start with, this is the
work on progressive simulation.
So the basic idea is that we
want to be able to compute
things, you know, resolution and
resolution progressive way. And
in this work was with a number
of amazing collaborators. So in
particular, Danny Kaufman, at
Adobe also started out with Alec
Jacobson and Raman, and others.
And so this is something that
she's been working on for a few
years now. And it's really
coming along the motivation is
basically you have, you know,
maybe you want to do design. So
if you have a scene like this,
you want to have like cloth, and
you want to lay things out with
with to do set design, or just
make a scene in a 3d modeling
tools, there's all kinds of
materials, there's contact,
maybe you want to have cloth and
shells and these sorts of
environments. And being able to
manipulate physical models is
really tedious, it's often very,
very slow. So you have this
basic problem of speed versus
fidelity, which, you know, this
is a reduced order modeling
session. So this is the basic
story, right? Like we want, you
want it to be good, but you also
want it to be fast. And there's
a trade off you have to make and
a lot of fun math to keep us
employed.
But, you know, currently, we can
do stuff like this, you know,
you can pull on a piece of
cloth, and then it can respond
in real time. Even somebody like
a GPU or CPU, whatever, there's
some amount of parallelism that
can be employed. And but you
can't really make a you know,
it's, it's, it's cool that does
this in real time, but it's also
limited. The other kinds of
things we have to deal with are
the simulators have all kinds of
limitations. So on the left, we
have like a, you know, animation
production quality system
Houdini, which allows us to
simulate this cloth, but it's
got jittering artifacts, it's
got intersections, maybe it has
other problems, depending on
your parameters that you didn't
tune expertly. On the right is
a, like the state of the art in
cloth design tool. Clothes
Marvelous Designer has all these
fantastic materials, but you
know, it's not stable. And you
maybe it'll blow up in some
cases. So you try again, right?
So how do you get all of these
things? You know, how do you get
reliable simulations that are
also fast, here's like a state
of the art simulator based on
incremental potential contact,
which is kind of like a, you
know, full blown elasticity
solver with barrier methods that
are robust and allow you to make
sure it'll always work and not
die. But it may take a long,
long time to get these results.
So minutes per frame, or, you
know, hours per simulation, but
you'll get something good. But
how do you design or work with
that if you're trying to do
design or animation so the other
thing that's really important is
control. And so it's not just
that you it's not just speeding
fidelity The point is you want
to use this for for you know,
art directable physics, you want
to design something, you want to
make a movie, you want to do
something with a human in the
loop. But if you can't, if it's
so slow, you can't do it or if
it's no good, it doesn't matter.
So here's a shot from
Incredibles two that I know some
people at Pixar spent a lot of
time thinking about, like you
have a scene where a character
is moving around, they have
clothing and they're interacting
with cloth and you know the
sheets and so on. They're coming
on the bed off the bed, and then
at some frame in the middle of
this animation, there's this
shot right and nothing in this
scene is by accident. You know
the way the cloth is exactly at
her knee line, not too high, not
too low. And is you know moving
when she comes on and off was by
was on purpose, right? So how do
you make sure things do what you
want, if you're working with a
physical simulator, usually, you
start integrating with initial
value problem, things go, and
then you get what you get,
right? But you want to control
things. So you need to have a
system that allows you to work
with it interactively,
essentially. And people that
made the shot the TDS, you don't
have to do all kinds of work to
design forces and ghosts forces
to push things just right and,
and then they change the
resolution and hope it works
better for the final shot. And
this is really hard to do. So if
we want interactive
interactivity and high quality
these are, you know, there's at
odds. So there's no free lunch.
But what we want to do is be
able to build a tool, initially,
I'm going to talk about quasi
static simulation. So things
like draping a piece of cloth,
maybe you want to explore
different materials, things that
are thin, have nice buckling,
and creases like this. Or maybe
you want to change the materials
as you go and move things
around. So this is just
initially we're going to talk
about quasi statics of cloth
things that have a flat rest
shape. And so how do we think of
progressive miss in graphics, so
there's all kinds of paradigms
for progressive simulation. So
on the left is like 3d
rendering, right, Monte Carlo
path tracing, you can, you can
render things coarse level, and
then refine it and get more
detail as you go. Right. And on
the right, we have progressive
meshes progressive geometry
where you can have a mesh, you
can simplify it, you can build a
hierarchy of meshes, and you can
refine along the way. But this
isn't, this isn't like, you
know, this isn't solid
mechanics. But this is these are
our ways people work with
progressive representations is
super useful level of detail,
make things fast, you can see
results right away, you can try
things out and then change
things, if you don't get you
would like for level of detail
with current state of the art
things like nanite system, and
Unreal Engine five, which uses
all kinds of really fine meshes
at different levels of detail.
And you can change these on the
fly artists, you know, experts
in fluid simulation, you know,
they use little strokes of paint
to get the background and then
they add more detail in a
progressive way. If you work in
solids, you know, then, you
know, you may sculpt things in a
progressive way to get details
where you want them. So how do
we do this for cloth simulation.
And I want to emphasize that
this is different from just the
idea where you simulate things
at a course level, and then you
in then you get something and
then you simulate in a fine
level. And in the limit, you
know, given some epsilon, I'll
tell you a delta and you'll get
an accurate result. We're not
trying to do refinement in a
progressive way to a limit
solution, like you do in
numerical analysis, we're
actually trying to progressively
refined a thing that we're
working on, which maybe isn't as
different from from the limit
case. And this is a really
important distinction. So for
example, here's the typical
problem with with direct
simulations. So you, you say,
Okay, I have to make the shot,
I'm gonna throw this blanket on
this guy, and you simulate a
cloth being put down at a low
resolution, and you get this
result, you say, Oh, I like
this. It goes under his chin.
And I don't know if you can see
my mouse, you see my mouse? Yep.
Yes, that's right. Yeah. Okay,
great. So it goes under his
chin, and he's got these nice
wrinkles. It's, this is what I
want. And so then you, you
change the resolution and rerun
the simulation, and wait a long
time, and you get this. And this
is typical, because now you've
got something that just doesn't
do the same thing. It's, it's
got fundamentally different
wrinkles, it caught on the other
guy's nose now, so the shot is
ruined. So if you run something
that a low res and get something
you like, just increasing the
resolution doesn't give you
something consistent,
necessarily, right. In some
cases, it may but in a lot of
cases, it doesn't. So everybody
who does fluid dynamics knows if
you run, you know, smoke at a
low res and you get something
that goes out looks nice in this
way, if you run it high res may
do something totally different
and may have, you know, all
kinds of more vortices, and so
on. And that's what you you
want, you know, if you're if
you're designing something, I'm
trying to do predictive
simulation, with fluids or
solids, but for art directable
physics, you want to direct
something quickly at low res and
then refine it in a way which
adds plausible detail but
doesn't necessarily do something
more accurate and different. You
want it to be consistent. So
this is the fundamental
challenge that we have to deal
with. Okay, so moving on.
Another challenge is cascading
methods are a natural approach
to this. So what they do is they
basically say I have a core sim.
It's doing something I like now
what I'm going to do, so I'm
saved draping this piece of
cloth on the left. I'm going to
now prolong it to a finer mesh,
and then and then use that as
initial guests for the next next
phase of relaxation, they have
this fine level simulation. And
this is kind of like warm
starting the quasi static
solver. And this, you know, this
is a reasonable thing to do. But
the problem is the course model
is garbage really. And so
whatever kinks increases and
locking artifacts, this course
cloth or shell model has are
going to be inherited by the
warm start to the next thing. So
now you've got this fine level
cloth model, which if it was
simulated, directly, would give
you something nice like this.
But now because you weren't
started it, you baked in these
creases, and locking the thing
is not in in very natural state.
And this is typical of these
kinds of methods. They're useful
for interactive design, because
they allow you to work course
and go fine, but they have all
these problems. So what we
really want is a better course
model, a smarter course model,
that is also consistent with the
finer scale. And then people
often, you know, multi grid and
multi level methods are related
to this, but they're for you
know, linear solvers or say
nonlinear solvers. But they're
not fundamentally for
progressive are directable.
Physics, they're just solvers.
Right? But we can use them too.
But they don't, they don't solve
this problem.
Okay, so the next thing I want
to talk about is just like, how
do we get interactive,
interactive, high quality cloth?
Well, the basic approach to this
is progressiveness, we're going
to get both of these by using a
progressive approach. And it's
also give us control. So we're
going to start with a course sim
and build up, in this case, a
quasi static simulation. So
we'll pose the cloth in some way
and of course scale. And then
what we can do is progressively
refine the simulation to get
something better, it's not the
same thing. Otherwise, why would
we just do that, it's going to
get more detail and more finer
wrinkles and things like that.
But it's still going to be
consistent with what we had. So
the rough shape of it will be
consistent, not going to
fundamentally do something else,
or pop out or fall down or
whatever. And so this will give
us a consistent representation
across scales. And it's also the
simulators reliable. So we're
going to use a rock solid
simulator won't allow any
intersections or, or artifacts,
and it's going to come at a
cost, but we're going to pay the
cost of the fine scale and work
quickly at the core scale. At
any point in time, you can
interrupt the simulation as it
goes from course to find and
change parameters or work with
it, and then just it'll just go
back. And you can keep doing
this over and over again. And
then, of course, the key thing
is that we'll have interactive
previews at every stage of the
process. So working course will
always be able to see what's
happening, and then we can
refine it. So that's the basic
idea of this original PCs.
method. And so here's the idea
of consistency. So a level zero,
we have something like this, but
as you refine it, the simulator
gets more detail, you can see
that the the quality of the
folds are finer and more
resolved. But the thing is not
fundamentally buckling or
creasing in a different way,
it's doing something that's
similar. And you could argue
this is not the most exciting
example, you know, it's just
like a handkerchief on a ball,
right? Nobody's gonna, you know,
go to the movies to see just
this. But it's, it's something
that you know, is clearly
consistent in space. With what's
happening here. Like, you could
measure the curvature and define
some measure of consistency,
which we did. The other thing
you can do is you can you can
change the materials as you go,
right. So a cool thing about
this is that you can, you know,
work with one material, and then
decide you want to change it and
get results for that too. So you
can be working at coarse scale,
and then try out different
things and rapidly explore the
space of, of possible materials
and outcomes, which is what you
want to do for design. The other
thing is that we don't, we can
avoid the artifacts, of course,
direct Sims, because Okay, so on
the left here, we just have a
cloth model that simulated at on
this mesh. And what you see is
what you get, it's simulated in
some, you know, it's basically
solving a statics problem with a
Newton solver, and you get
something like this. But it has
a lot of artifacts that are
representative of the kind of
failures of just really coarse
cloth mesh models. And whereas
this one here is smarter. And
the reason it's smarter is
basically because the course
model that we're using here is
doing multiscale model
reduction, it's basically using,
it's basically using elastic
forces and energies to find at
the finest level mesh, and then
restricting these down to this.
So it's using a much better
shape model for its elastic
energies. And so this thing
behaves like it's actually a
finer scale model. So comes more
of a cost to do this, but it's
better than just using the
course model itself. And the
other thing is that this model,
because it knows about the fine
scale energies will when you
refine the mesh still behave in
a similar way. So that's going
to allow us to have consistency
across scales, because the
course model is actually, you
know, knows about the fine scale
model in some specific ways. And
when you refine the meshes, then
you get something here on the
right, which is consistent with
what we had on the left. Okay,
it looks similar. Whereas the
one on the on the left is got
some different artifacts, things
move around, and it's not as
consistent. But the also, the
other thing is that when we
refine this and solve it at the
fine scale, it is actually a
converged Newton solution
corresponds to, you know,
approximate minima of the
energies. Okay? Let me see.
Okay, so this gives us speed up
over a direct simulation. So
here we can, we can drape the
PCs simulation at a coarse
scale, and then when it gets to
its relaxed position, then
refine it. And this is better
than just directly working with
the fine model itself, because
you know, this is just going to
take a longer time, because it's
just time, it's basically just
time stepping lots of these
degrees of freedom in the Newton
solver. So working course, is
much faster. And in some cases,
that can be arbitrarily fast,
because you can't actually get
the work done if you're working
on a course at a fine scale. So
this is a sped up a session of
somebody working with the system
to build an example I showed you
in the very beginning. So
there's a bust of us have a
character, and then this piece
of cloth is being draped over
over it, and then interactively
manipulating it to produce what
you want. So like the typical
design processes, you don't know
what the final outcome is,
you're trying to work with the
system and the media to figure
out what's possible. So they're
changing material parameters.
And, and then they're also
changing the configuration and
moving things around. So in this
case, you can translate, rotate,
and scale the collider. And then
and the system of, you know,
pushes that out in this case,
because you've specified some
infeasible state, and then grab
it, you basically grab the cloth
and move it around like you
would in a typical system. And
in this case, the person is
trying to move the cloth around
the character. And so this is
the system. And so then as you
get closer to your goal, then
you can, you can go ahead and
refine the actual resolution,
and it gets, of course, much
slower. But by this point, the
person's done. So the artist has
basically found something they
like they've increased the
resolution, and then they just
wait for the higher quality
results to come into play. But
all of the design work is done
in a more rapid prototyping
course scale. Okay, so here's
the final result. So this is
what they what they designed.
And you know, it's only
1.5 1015 100 triangles. And this
can be solved very quickly, if
you know, direct solver,
basically. And then this gets
refined and the end result takes
much longer. But you know, you
get something that's consistent,
you have to wait, but you don't
have to, you don't have any
anxiety, just have a coffee and
relax, it's going to work out.
And here's the final render of
that of that, of that draping
design. So if you tried to work
directly on the fine sim, it
would be too slow. If you didn't
work on the fine sim, you just
work. And of course sim wouldn't
be consistent. So this solves
both those problems. So the
basic idea of the method should
keep an eye on the time because
I'm going to run out of you
know, run out of time here. So
the basic idea of the method is
you basically want to take the
cloth and some initial state and
then get to some final converge
state. You have a course
preview, and then you can
progressively refine this across
levels in a way that preserves
the integrity of the simulation
doesn't introduce intersections
or artifacts. So this is done in
an incremental potential
formulation. So we're basically
minimizing some energy of the
system, where you have membrane
and bending energies of the
elastic simulation and then you
all this contact, a barrier for
contact friction and then a
strain limiting potential which
is this is sort of incremental
potential contact formulation.
And this will guarantee things
don't interpenetrate. And it's
solved using Newton with line
search and some robust solver.
And it may take a long time, but
it'll, it'll get there. And and
in order to deal with the
resolutions, we have a
prolongation approach where you
basically have this mesh. And
it's basically subdivided or
prolonged to a finer, finer
mesh. And then at each level,
basically, you essentially want
to solve this problem where
there's a level L, you have some
energy for that level. And then
you could just solve each one of
these separately, it would kind
of look like this. And, you
know, each one would have a
different, different minima. And
we want to relate them by this
initial gas x bar, which is
basically our warm start.
But we don't want to do this
exactly. So the problem is, if
you just solve each levels
energy separately, then you're
gonna have some problems. The
other thing I should mention is
that in order to make the
process coherent, and time for
somebody working with the
system, we have a sort of pseudo
time by adding an extra,
basically penalty term, which
corresponds to like this kinetic
energy thing. So you have a mass
norm on the change in position,
which basically produces a
kinetic energy type energy in
the system. So the problem I
talked about before, where you
take a course model, and then
you refine it and use a warm
start with this will give you
artifacts for membrane locking,
because the coarse model is a
bad model. And it's going to put
in artifacts that when you
refine as a warm start will be
hard to undo. So if you like
crease or not up your
simulation, the cloth is going
to have a hard time on doing
that. And it may just say fine,
I'll just stay here. And but
it's not a natural state for the
cloth to have these mesh
artifacts in it from a coarse
scale. So instead of using each
level separately, what we're
going to do is we're going to
use the fine scale energies at
at the coarser scales. And so in
order to do that, we have a
prolongation operator, which
basically refines a solution or
vector from one level to the
finest level. And then what we
do is we evaluate the contact
energies for the barrier
friction and string limiting at
the specific scale for the mesh
you have. But the but the you
know, the membrane and the
bending energies are going to be
for the finest level, okay? And
this will make make it behave
much better. It turns out, you
could do these at a finer scale,
but it doesn't it's not it's not
worth it alternative. So this
will basically will have good
contact handling constraints at
the current level for this
specific geometry. And then
we'll refine, basically evaluate
the energies here, and those
will get restricted back and
unusual multiscale model
reduction kind of way. And so in
this case, then, right. So this
gets all put in a Newton solver.
And in order to solve this, of
course, you have to compute
derivatives and Hessians. And
things like this. And so this
can get expensive. So the
gradient of the energy is just
the forces on the system at the
scale. And then the Hessian
involves two parts, the first
part is going to be the mass
matrix, which is just there for
for keeping it from, you know,
just for for coherence. But then
we have the potential, the
gradient of the the energies of
the fine scale for the elastic
energies and then the contact
hessian. So this one is easy,
because it's at the current
level, but this one involves
fine scale information. So
there's the usual kind of, you
know, how do you evaluate the
stiffness matrix for this
reduced system using the fine
scale model. In this case,
because we're just doing a
Newton problem, we can do an
inexact Newton solve and just
use the this hessian at the
current level. And so this is
this is a simplification, which
will will speed things up quite
a bit. And so then the Newton
set proceeds. And if it's done,
right, you get to a reasonable,
feasible minimum. And this is
this is what the system does.
And then in order to get to the
next step, you just keep doing
this incrementally, and then you
converge to the solution. The
one thing you have to watch out
for is when you change from one
resolution to the next you can
mess things up by changing the
contact state. So we have to
make sure that there's an
intersection free up sampling
that happens. And so we do this
by doing basically a polyhedral
subdivision. We just refine the
parameterization not the
geometry. And then and then we
do a continuous collision
detection to basically allow
this thing to relax and take its
natural state and this Countries
intersections. But this is, if
it's done properly in this way,
then we're able to, you know,
make sure that that we don't
mess things up. And it has to
also work for strain limiting,
because if you allow things to
get pushed around, as they
change from run resolution to
neck, you could introduce a lot
energy by stretching something
that doesn't want to stretch.
And so that that energy has got
to be satisfied, too. So there's
a whole tedious sequence of
steps that allow us to do this,
but we can change resolutions as
we go. And then if you want to
go back and fix things you can
and so this is, this is the
interactive workflow. Okay, how
am I doing for time, so there's
some consistency with with the
curvature, if we look at mean
curvature between levels for our
model, versus previous cascaded
approaches, we basically went in
every every scenario that we
looked at in the paper, it's
just more consistent. And we can
also have nested collision
geometry, not just a cloth, but
we could have, you know,
progressive representations of
scenes that, you know, allow us
to refine the geometry of the
scene as we go. So this helps
with speeding up collision
detection basically. So here's a
gallery of some different
simulations that were made,
changing the bending stiffness,
the materials, and then here's
an interactive workflow. So
after nine minutes of working
with a simulator, which is not
much time, given that this to do
the solve, it's like, it's about
that time to actually do one
solve, right? So you can't work
at the fine scale. If we work in
a progressive way we can get get
the work done. And here's a
larger scene, I'm just going to
sort of speed this up. But
somebody's you know, working
with the system at core scales,
and there's multiple layered
pieces of cloth that are
sticking together. And the thing
that responds and of course, way
and then when you stop moving
things, it starts refining and
adding more detail until you
change it again. So this is a
it's a fully responsive system.
This is a prototype, it's not a
product, but you get the idea.
And then you have multiple
pieces of interacting cloth. And
in the final thing, you have as
many triangles as you want.
Okay, so this is just for cloth.
The next part is for shells. And
I want to go through this more
quickly, because more
complicated, but basically is
have non smooth rest states. So
they they have geometry, that
when you refine them, they're
not just a flat piece of cloth
that's bent. It's got some
inherent, nonzero rest angles
for the for the shells, shells
are interesting. They have all
kinds of interesting behavior.
But they're, you know, more more
expensive to simulate. So the
usual problem of speed versus
fidelity is even more
interesting for Shell. So if
you've, if you try to use a
really core simulation, you'll
miss all these fine details and
buckling effects that you need a
result shell simulation for. And
you'll get all kinds of locking,
locking effects. I'm just going
to speed this up. So here's like
a direct simulation, of course
scale, you get all kinds of
artifacts, it's just terrible.
So how do you get this with a
shell simulation? The same sort
of thing we did before. Only
works for subdivision
connectivity, which also, it's
subdivided a flat shape to a
flat shape, but now it with with
a shell, you know, now we can do
subdivision surfaces, but
there's no details, how do we
take a specific detailed mesh
and work with it in this way, we
can't assume it's a subdivision
model. So we want to take
arbitrary fine geometry, and
then build a hierarchy from that
and use that in a progressive
simulation framework. But this
is difficult, because it's not
just a repeated subdivision.
Everything's not in plain sight.
Okay, so this is where this
method progressive shell quasi
statics comes from still quasi
statics, but we take a high
resolution model and decimate it
using like a quadric
simplification class of method,
not that one exactly. And then
from that we have a hierarchy to
refine it. And so here's the
simulation that somebody's
working on the course model on
and they can, you know, pose
this character however they want
and then refine it and get the
simulation corresponding. So
this is like a shell balloon
character that has some some
details.
Okay, so at level zero, you get
consistent solutions as these
things evolve. And you get extra
detail and geometry that gets
added in it's not just a smooth
limit surface and it's just
fundamentally better so the the
progressive simulations course
model is smart because it knows
about fine scale energies. So
when you refine it, it's it's
consistent as well. And it
avoids locking our effects and
we can upset Pull the contacts.
So here as we add more detail,
we don't get any penetrations,
and even in this pretty
challenging case, things just
resolve and work. And so you can
do something at a core
simulation scale, and then keep
increasing resolution, the
contacts get resolved in,
there's no inner penetrations,
and everything, you know, just
works. The details of it are,
are fascinating, but also,
they're gonna cause me to run
out of time. Let me see. So
we're going to do quasi statics,
again, what we really want to do
is dynamics. That's the next
paper before the bubbles. So let
me let me just speed this up a
bit. So previously, we did quasi
statics. But now, this only
works for subdivision
connectivity. And so the thing
we have here are, we have the
coarse level proxy energies
using fine scale elastic energy.
And then we have a safe
initialization. But this only
works for in plane stuff. So we
could assume that we just
refined the triangle in plane.
So now, we can use the
simplification to get a coarse
model but to refine it, this is
a problematic thing. And then we
also have to make sure that when
we when we prolong ate it, we
don't introduce inner
penetrations, which is now
harder. And so those those are
the two things in this paper
does, there's from prior work, I
want to skip that doesn't solve
it messes things up and add
skills forces, skip this. And
this one, it makes things dense.
So we want to fast and sparse
prolongation. So this is based
on edge collapse. And there's
basically there's the basic
thing is that when you want to
add an extra degree of freedom
back, you can do it in the plane
of the triangle using a
barycentric intrinsic
coordinate, but you still need
to go out of the plane to pop
the inflate the shell. And this
is the extrinsic prolongation
part. And so as we do this, we
basically, we basically track a
local frame of this triangle,
and figure out where the
barycentric coordinate of the
coordinate is. And then we add
an additional displacement off
this in the local frame. And
this is how the prolongation
works. And there's a we show
that this actually works. And
it's, it's stable, and it gives
us good energies, which is the
key thing for simulation. And so
we're able to then pro elongate
this and add detail and in the
system will work. In order to
initialize it, we need to make
sure that there's no
interpenetration introduced. And
so in order to do that, as you
add more degrees of freedom, you
have to check for collisions.
And when you're doing these edge
expansions, so that you maintain
a feasible simulation with no
inner penetrations, and there's
some details about how this has
to be done in a robust way.
Because you could have things
which are like, you know, of
course, shell model, which is
like, you know, some origami,
you know, satellite thing all
packed in, and then you want to
add degrees of freedom, and
there's no room, you have to
make sure that this is done
robustly. And so there's a part
of the paper which is dedicated
to this part to to make sure
that you can inflate things in a
way which is done safely. And I
won't get into this. There's a
randomized search method that
guarantees that it works. And so
if you if you use this, then
you're able to deal with
challenging cases, like the one
we saw where you're twisting the
cloth, you can twist it right
up, and it will still figure out
how to inflate this thing and
not introduce any
interpenetration artifacts.
Let's see the paper for details.
It's also parallelized by
figuring out local regions to do
this, okay. So once you do that,
then you're able to do
prolongation with these models,
they preserve the classic shell
energies, for symmetric
inversions. They're better than
the previous cloth approach,
because they don't have they
have a better better
approximation of the energies at
finer scales. They don't have
parameterization artifacts as
much as loop subdivision did.
And so they just do a better job
of, of course approximations to
the model. And then when you
refine them, they're better. So
here's a shell model with a with
a crush example. And then as you
refine the simulation from here,
you get something that's
consistent. This is a whimsical
example where you're simulating
that of course scale and then
refine it and you get something
consistent. Another inflation
example and let me just keep
moving along and run out of
time. Okay, so for animation
then this doesn't address
animation. So previously, we
just looked at quasi statics.
And in this new work, basically,
we can actually add the dynamics
back in. So here's a good
example where you have this
character, you want to throw
them through some hoops. And
you're working with a
simulation, it's incredibly
slow. This is a real time
capture, actually animating this
character in Houdini, and he
doesn't get through the hoops,
you say, oh, I need to increase
my velocity, or I need to move
the hoops or something like
this. So it's very tedious to
get these things done. But after
some work, you know, eventually
get the character to fly through
the hoops. This is using
Houdini's velum simulator. It's
a position based dynamic
simulator. But as you increase
the resolution, the simulator
changes behavior. So he goes to
the next level, it does this and
you go, Oh, no, I just spent
like an hour getting this guy to
go through the dang hoop. And
now you know, it doesn't go
through if you let it go up
another level of resolution to
the full model. This solver
isn't like consistent across
scales. This is a you know, a
kind of absurd example, if you
had a better simulator, like
IPC, or finite element shell
model, it would have less
variation, but it would still be
different. And so what you what
you can do at one scale, you
know, we can refine quasi
statically. But how about
dynamics? How do you refine
dynamics and still get something
that's consistent across scales.
And this is what the progressive
dynamics work does, you simulate
something that, of course scale
with a enriched course model
with this multi scale model
reduction smart's to it. And
then when you refine it, you're
gonna get something that also
produces qualitatively similar
behavior with now more detail.
And so he's still bunks his nose
and the in the way the animator
want it. And as you keep adding
more and more detail, as you get
to the final simulation, so this
can run offline, but you'll be
sure that it's going to produce
something consistent. It's not
the same as doing the original
fine scale simulation, because
it's biased, to be consistent
with a coarse scale model,
right. So this is the key thing
that gives you control. And so
this works for scenes like this
one, which are really
complicated. On the on the top,
right, you know, the, here's
these whimsical sky dancer
models where everything gets
designed to the course of scale.
So that it's, it's got the right
materials, you know, if you've
never made one of these
animations before, maybe you
don't know the wind speed to use
to get these guys to jiggle and
dance and in a fun way. So you
have to explore it the course
scale, and then you can refine
and you'll get something that
does the same thing, not like
blows like crazy or stretches
too much or falls on the floor,
right? So you get consistent
progressive dynamics. Okay, so I
don't have time to talk about
the details of this. And this
work is just coming out at
SIGGRAPH this summer. So check
out heiresses webpage for the
progressive dynamics work that
will be out shortly. And that's,
that's it for this part of the
talk. There's a whole bunch of
other results that show, you
know, basically, you get a scale
flag model that's consistent
across scales. Whereas if you
did a full simulation, just the
regular shell simulation, in
orange here after this one,
basically, you get something
that diverges the simulations at
different levels of detail,
don't do the same thing, which
is what you hope because
otherwise, everybody just do
everything at core skills. Okay,
so that's the end of that part
of the talk. The next part of
the talk is this one. So I've
got just a little bit of time
for bubbles. See, maybe let's
keep the questions to the end.
Otherwise, I'll run out.
I'll take it take your time
talk. Okay.
Okay, so the last part, I just
wanted to show you some cool
work that Congri along with
other collaborators at Adobe and
in Stanford, that we've done on
making water sounds better. So
I'm super excited about about
sound synthesis in general, and
then Waterstones. But the here's
a, here's a experiment we did
back at Cornell, we recorded
lots of droplets in bubble
sounds. And the basic problem is
that when a bubble is created,
it vibrates very strongly to
compress the air and, and the
energy of the mass of the water.
And it can produce notable
sounds in particular, so
basically have bubbles that have
a frequency that's inversely
proportional to their diameters
has been known for almost 100
years. And so small bubbles
produce these classic musical
tones in isolation, and this can
be used to make sounds. But you
know, people have studied
bubbles and their properties for
how the frequencies depend on
shape, how they may coupled
together has been explored more
recently. There's this great
book by A timely thing called
the acoustic bubble, which talks
about all kinds of things that
people care about this a lot,
because for remote sensing for
climate models understand their
ocean mixing effects is
absolutely critical. There's so
many things we do. In computer
graphics, we had a paper back in
2009, that looked about how to
how to use bubbles to make sound
for animations. So we produce
various bubbles using a
stochastic approach where we
would look at how some particle
level set or particles near the
surface would get mixed into the
fluid, and then use that to
generate bubbles in a stochastic
way, and then just use the
manure bubble frequency just
based on the one over the
diameter of the bubble. And this
tended to make the the sounds
pretty shrill. Like we ended up
with a lot of high pitch sounds,
it was kind of harsh, you know,
early sounds always bad, but it
gets better over time. And then
so follow on work by moss said,
look, they only use this
pulsating mode of the bubble,
there's these higher mode,
higher oscillation modes. But
these tended to also introduce
higher frequency sounds, which
made them even more, you know,
shrill, essentially, in my
opinion. So this doesn't really
solve the problem. And then in
order to figure out how to do
better, we went to full two
phase flow simulations where we
had incompressible bubbles, and,
you know, we competed with with
a simulator called jerris, which
was very expensive, ran a
supercomputer. And we got these
more higher fidelity water
simulations. And to see does
this make it sound better. And
so this was a lot more
expensive. We also had a solver
to figure out the bubble
frequencies based on a capacitor
and solver of associated Laplace
problem. And we get things like
this. So here's what they sound
like.
So all of these are have some
watery, bubbly character, but
they're missing something,
right? One thing is that the
frequencies are just generally
too high. There's the other
aspect of the radiation and the
transfer in the air domain,
which we'll talk about a little
bit later. These ones on the top
included this one on the bottom
ignores it. But the problem that
we had is a lot of these
frequencies are just fire than
we observed in practice. And in
one thing that is happening is
if you consider a bubble
oscillating independently, it
has this damped sinusoid kind of
behavior. But the frequencies
are much higher, because when
this bubble is pulsating, the
coupling with the neighboring
bubbles has been ignored. But in
practice, if you include
coupling, then you get more
interesting variations in this
instead of just a ping of a
damped oscillator like we had
before. Here, which is kind of
digital and in shrill. Having
this coupling is more
interesting fluctuations in the
waveform. And it also introduces
more effective maths and the
systems the frequencies are
lower. And it produces lower
frequency sounds, which is
really fundamentally important
when you go to the ocean. And
here are a giant wave crash, the
bubbles are really tiny, if you
played them all as independent
oscillators, with the one over
diameter frequencies, it would
be just just shrill and loud as
can be. But when you introduce
coupling, the ocean gets lower
frequencies and roars and this
has been known in acoustic
bubble community for some time.
So here's this example by Leroy
where they basically couple a
small number of bubbles together
and you already get reduction
from three kilohertz down to
like, you know, two point
whatever. And in practice, if
you have like, you know,
increase the number of bubbles
in some test volume by a factor
of 1000, you can get an or like
a 10 times reduction in
frequency. So that'll get you
from two kilohertz to 200 hertz
and give you a low frequency
roar. And so, this is the key
thing that we want to include
and which was missing in all
these previous works. So, in
this case, we have an uncoupled
simulation on the left, which is
which is coming in and you get
something like this in the
spectrogram. And on the right we
have a recording of a of a
different but comparable
scenario. And what you have is
this lower frequency load that
comes in have the stuff near the
surface, which is splattering as
increasing as as it pours fills
up the glass the resonance
increases, but you have this
lower frequency effect, which is
we argue due to coupling. And so
this is what was missing before
are one of the things that is
missing. And we want to look at
that. And so here's a here's an
here's a preview of our results.
argue that this is fundamentally
better than what we had before.
This is being computed with a
couple bubble oscillators, but
also the sound radiation is
doing a time domain wave
equation. And here's the
previous uncoupled results with
a better wave equation.
So as it pours in the bubbles
just all sound the same
frequency all the time, they
don't have the variation in the
pitch. And so you can see this
down here, you can see these,
this coupling adds this lower
frequency low, which we were
hoping to get. And at any point
in the simulation, you can look
at the modes of oscillation of
this bubble cloud and see what's
going on. So the low frequency
mode is lower than any of the
individual bubbles by quite a
bit. Okay, so these simulations
we're gonna do for time these
simulate try to make hit the
time. So these simulations were,
were computed using Houdini,
which is a animation tool that
is used in industry. So this is
like a flip simulation, which is
a fluid implicit particle
simulation. So it's a single
phase flow, the bubbles are
created using a particle based
model which stochastically
creates bubbles, and they split
and merge in some procedural
way, is very ad hoc. So the the,
the sound quality is not coming
from the fidelity of the
simulation. This is a very low
fidelity particle simulation of
bubbles in this big glass pour
example, for example, and then
the coupling is basically the
thing which makes it sound.
Okay, so we introduced a
practical framework for
simulating couple bubble sounds,
it involves a coupling model
based on the mass matrix and an
efficient way to compute
airborne sound on the GPU. Just
to give you an idea, so the
basic model of a bubble is just
an independent oscillator. So in
a pressure volume frame, we have
forcing due to pressure and then
the volume fluctuations of this
bubble are modeled, here's this
v. And then so this is a simple
harmonic oscillator, if you have
a bunch of bubbles, they're all
the couple simple harmonic
oscillators. And once you
introduce coupling, the pressure
from one bubble can can drive
the other bubbles essentially.
So as you know, it changes its
volume, there's some, you know,
incompressible, velocity field
that causes pressure changes
elsewhere. And so this
introduces coupling, and if you
symmetrize the system, you end
up with a mass matrix
formulation, something like
this. So you basically have off
diagonal entries in your mass
matrix coupling these bubbles
together. So this is a weird
system, usually where you have
like, you know, you're used to a
sparse stiffness matrix. But
this is basically just due to
the gas and surface tension. So
it's diagonal, and you have all
the off diagonal coupling in the
mass matrix, which is a bit
awkward, because if you want to
timestep, this, now you have a
dense matrix. So the coupling is
smaller if they're farther away,
but bubbles come and go. So you
add a new bubble, you have to
increase the mass matrix size,
if you did pops or something,
you have to decrease it. So this
is introduces changes in this.
And then you have this problem
that you have the time step at
really high rates. So this is an
awful space to be in. Like even
if you want to do a, you know,
forward Euler time step or some,
you know, midpoint, you'd still
have like a dense matrix, you
have to solve to do an explicit
salt method. So this is this is
awful and tiny time steps. So
the way to deal with this, we
factorize the mass matrix
Szalinski. And then it's
positive definite, we can
interpolate the inverses. And
they'll still be positive. So
this is good. And so this allows
us to interpolate these
factorizations along the way, to
make something go fast, the
matrix can still lose positive
definiteness as bubbles get
closer, it's not guaranteed. So
we regularize the Symmetrize
mass matrix, and this, we can
show this fixes it. And then you
can also do low rank update
tricks, which is fun. So here's
like a reproduction of this
classic example, where they have
a bubble net. And then you can
show the modes that this system
produces, which correspond to
the what was observed in the
previous approach
experimentally. And these are
the modes of of the bubbles in
the class example showing a
pretty low frequencies for this
bubble cloud the lowest mode,
which allows us to capture these
interesting effects. The last
part is just the how to compute
the sound in the in the air
domain. We don't listen to Eigen
values or bubble frequencies. We
Your air pressure fluctuations.
So we took the previous approach
where we had like a time domain
wave solver with basically cut
cells. And you know, those
because those pressures, and
then we basically put this in a
GPU wave solver. But the problem
with this is that how do we do
this on like cut cells and
things like that on the GPU are
really hard to do. So what we're
going to do is we're going to
basically simplify the way we
evaluate the pressures, we're
not using the boundary data,
sorry, I'm going to go too fast
here. Basically, evaluate the
surface accelerations using a
simplified model. And then in
order to compute the pressure in
the air domain, we use a sample
and hold approach to basically
solve the waves in the air
domain. And this is because
there's so many abrupt changes
and popping artifacts, the
previous solvers were just not
robust, they would die. Or they
would introduce artifacts, even
if they work. So what we did is
we, we basically just freeze the
geometry at certain times, and
then use the boundary condition
model to evaluate the boundary
data on these frozen geometries.
And then we use this parallel
and time approach that came up
we came up with in our previous
paper where we can, for each of
these Sims, they basically
generate some nonzero data and
get a sound clip nonzero data
sound clip, and then we sum all
these together. And then we get
the sound of each of these
instances in time, it's just
like a frame based sound
rendering approach. And so each
of these frozen geometries can
use just fixed geometry in a GPU
solver. So it's really fast. And
then we sum these together and
get the sound. And so we get a
significant speed up. And it's a
much simpler implementation.
Over the CPU implementation,
this was also this is running on
a cluster at in the cloud. So
this is much more expensive than
it looks. But even still, it's
just much faster. Even on one
one GPU, okay? The coupling
simulations are on the CPU, but
you know, they're just doing
Cholesky. And it's it's very
cheap, even with this number of
oscillators. So here's some
results just visually. So as we
add coupling, we get more low
frequency lobes and these
things, more low frequency
character pushes things down,
which makes it sound a little
better. And for example, in
these pouring examples, you get
these lower lobes of low
frequency content, which makes
it better. So I encourage you to
go look at the videos online,
you can see these and hear them
at higher quality, then you can
probably see over over this
WebEx call. Here's the poor
example, from a simulation that
has similar character to a
recording, although recordings
are always better and different,
for all kinds of reasons. So
anyway, so adding coupling and
improving the efficiency and
fidelity of the of the radiated
sound is our areas that we can
improve. So in the end, this
adds more low frequencies makes
things sound better, and makes
things faster, too. And in in
future and ongoing work, we're
still improving this and making
it more practical, we want to be
able to do all these kinds of
effects. And in make it easy for
people to author them. But also
not just the water, but
everything as well. And so our
current approach is like how to
make a unified GPU solver, which
supports everything and doesn't
suffer from all the complexities
of meshing and interface
boundary condition handling. And
yeah, so that's, I think that's
it. I'll just end here. And if
anybody has any questions, I'll
be happy to answer them. So
thanks so much for having me.
Thank you. Thank you so much for
the wonderful talk talk. Okay,
so let's have a q&a sessions.
Does anyone have a questions?
You can unmute yourself and then
ask questions. Mike, I have a
one questions okay. The first
part of the talk you talk about
like going from course to the
fine skills and you know, the
closed source animations that
was the method was applied. I
was wondering close a lot of
simulations we are interested in
is like actual fracture or the
crack properties and those
techniques, how can we extend it
to those actual carrying and not
only the, you know, the bending,
right?
Yeah, I think. Yeah, so
extending the progressive
framework to to fracture and
seems like that is Yeah, yeah,
it's kind of the part of the
question is like, what does that
even mean? Right? Like I think,
you know, if it's a dynamic
process, then extending it so
that you can tear things in a
coarse way and then refine them
and get more detail, right? I
mean, that would, that would be
a natural thing to want to do,
because the process is very
expensive. And it's also often
people have artistic goals, or I
think a lot of the way people
deal with artistic goals are
fractures, they have fracture
patterns they impose or they
have like enrichment functions,
where they try to make it
satisfy certain types of
interface. displacements and so
on for the fracture. Yeah, I
don't know, I think that's an
interesting thing we're
interested in Eris is actually
in the call is, she's done a lot
of work on trying to extend
progressive causes statics and
dynamics to support volumes and
other effects. So doing
fracture, and you know, all
these other more complicated
phenomenon is definitely
something we'd love to be able
to do. But yeah, it's lots open
questions with geometry for
sure. Got it. Okay.
Shaima, you raise your hand, I'm
guessing. Yeah. But
thank you so much for the
presentation. So I can also
maybe switch on. Yeah. So thank
you so much for the for the
presentation was really amazing.
I enjoyed it a lot. And they
learn many things. Today. I have
a question about the consistency
measures of the of the methods,
because I also am a PhD student
work with the reduction methods
for for physics based simulation
for computer graphics. And what
we usually do is that we, when
we have a reduction method, then
we compare to what the full
order model solution will give
us. And then we have this error
measure, let's say compared to
the full order model, what what
does that you explain the you
showed us that sometimes when
you have the very fine mesh, it
does not give you the same
behavior that that you that you
want and like this sticking on
the nose of the armadillo image
that you showed us at the very
beginning. So I was surprised
that a finer mesh would not
maybe give me the solution that
I'm aiming at. So if you can
please elaborate on the
consistency measures, because
that that would be the main
measure. And one one more thing
that is related to the same
question. Because you also
showed us that when you change
the refinement level of the
mesh, it changes behavior. So
that was like the hoop jumping
example, then how do you control
the course level? Mesh? Where do
you start from, so that you get
the level of details or the
behavior that you are aiming at?
In your creations? Okay,
yeah, so there's two things
happening here. So on one hand,
there's like the traditional,
you know, refinement problem
that, you know, predictive
scientists, like yourself have,
where you have a simulation
model at some each
discretization level, you
refine, that make that smaller,
and it converges to the true
solution, right? That's, you
know, that's a, you know, a well
founded, you know, consistent
stability, convergence, you
know, all that stuff, we know
him. The thing with progressive
simulation is, you know, as you
in that model, as you refine
them the mash, you get just
different solutions, it gets
closer to the true solution. But
it's not maybe what you want,
right? Because you want to
design at a coarse scale, and
get something that you like and
then refine it. But as you
refine it, it may do something
different, just that's the way
physics is, right. And so the
whole trick of the progressive
formulation is to make the
coarse model more expensive, LP
it, because it's using some
things from the fine scale, but
not everything. It's not a full
fine scale thing. It's still
doing a low dimensional matrix
probably solve still small like
in dimensional model reduction.
But it has some energies from
the fine scale elastic part,
which make it think it's doing
something better. Okay. And so
that allows it to behave more
like a full scale model, so that
when you refine it, it's still
it's still predictive enough
that it behaves in a similar
way. But it's not basically
allowed to be to converge to the
full thing. In the for example,
in the dynamics case, and so
it's biased. The course model is
better than just a regular
course model because using fine
scaling energies, but it's
biased in the way Eris is doing
the optimization for the time
stepping scheme, because it's
trying to balance two things for
the dynamics, for example, the
dynamics is balancing one where
it's just going to take a course
simulation, and then, and then
prolong it, refine it, so that
it's just going up. If you do
that, you know, the course sim
will be prolonged, and every
frame will correspond and look
great. But when you play back
that fine seal animation, it's
going to pop and jitter and
wrinkle this way. And that way,
it's going to be incoherent in
time. The other scheme is just
to say, Oh, I'm just going to,
you know, prolonging the initial
thing, and then run all the
simulations at each level
independently in time time step,
then, but now, it'll be coherent
in time, but there'll be
divergent across scales. So so
what what the the progressive
dynamics approach does, it has
an optimizer for the times, it's
basically formulates the time
stepping scheme as an optimizer,
which balances two things. One,
you know, how you're solving,
say, backward Euler in time, but
also it's balancing how it
relates to the course scale.
Basically, it's, you know, it's
using an initial guess that's
related to the course scale. So
it's balancing the errors in
temporal dynamics momentum, and
it's balancing errors in
refinement across scales. And if
it does that, right, then you
get this whole space time, you
know, framework, which is smooth
and coherent. And that's,
that's, but it's not predictive,
right. It's not like an accurate
simulation, like you would
refine it, it's going to be
biased to the course model. So
you pick a course model, which
is good enough, but still fast.
And then you and then you can
refine in this, this this space
time framework. Yeah.
And then various services, this
spring connection to the coarse
mesh between the fine and coarse
mesh, the penality term that you
introduced to the energy, I
guess, what the norm x minus xB?
Something like, yeah, that
was basically what makes the no
so that that that term, the
difference in the the changes in
the position and a mass weighted
norm, basically, just like, you
can separate that is just a
kinetic energy energy model, you
know, if you look at like a
position based frame formulation
of backward Euler, in position
based optimization, so that's,
that's just kinetic energy. The
thing that is in for the
progressive dynamics to work in
a coherent way is in the paper,
which you know, Eris is gonna
put on the web. And any day now
I'm sure so.
Yeah, looking forward.
Thank you for your questions.
Thank you. All right.
Thank you. Thank you so much. Is
there any other questions in
white? line after line after 11?
So
it's probably good. Yeah. And if
anybody has any questions, feel
free to reach out to me or, or
either my students and I'm sure
they'll be able to answer your
questions. Yeah. Thank you.
Thank you. Thanks so much for
having me.
It's good to see you. Thank you.
Thank you. Bye, bye. All right.
That ends the seminar today.
Okay. Bye. Bye, everybody.